proud of the fact that he's still the
all-time leader in games in minutes
for the toronto franchise that meant a
lot to him
to be able to play that much
play that well for
toronto
live under a d a.d falls down turnover
so just lost his footing as he came down
down to earth
and lost his shoe through a shoe that's
what he did he lost his shirt
i just don't understand how you can lose
your shoe
they don't strap him up very tight
oh abs been tossed
he's out of the game
they let him play on before a.d could
put the shoe on
that's why he got upset about it i think
and i'm assuming that's why
he already had one technical so yeah
second technical and he's uh
early shower
a.d done
so it's a technical foul which means
it's stu mentioned two t's gone 20
points
[Applause]
boy that was an emphatic
by the official the choice of uh the
choice of verbiage must have been nice
yeah
i mean that was emphatic
87-66
[Applause]
you see he's trying to put his shoe on
but we can't see what the
lips are saying
[Applause]
yet another what is that his third
three-point opportunity of the quarter
i believe that's right derek jones jr
another and one
and they're just pouring it on the
lakers right now 89.66
[Applause]
that's the second ejection by the way
for anthony davis in his career
[Applause]
a.d in his 10th year the eight-time
all-star
[Applause]
third quarter woes have rear their ugly
head against